ce matinve rando pays vous propose cette
semaine une randonnée dans le sud
use pourant ce matin
réveille au milieu l'océan Indien il a
encore
moins rendez-vous à bassvallé dans le
Sud Sauvage pourtant point miracle
monter en direction du git après le git
attention à l'état de la route
forestière si votre véhicule le permet
vous pourrez la suivre jusqu'au kiosque
il a pas changé est toujours pareil pour
raconte histoire créol
le sentier assez sauvage et fermé permet
la découverte d'un milieu forestier
riche même dans cette poche de
végétation envahie la seule du sentier
mi recè la présence d'une espèce très
rare ça c'est une une plante rare qui
est protégé qu'on
appelle tourné forciainata et on l'a
découvert depuis peu parce que
paravantéta op perché dans la C c'est le
cyclone biza qui
l' l' rabattu sur le sentier du coup on
a pu donc on a pu la répertorier donc on
peut voir que les au niveau des fruits
ont petite forme un peu particulière en
forme de de queue de scorpion hein donc
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à les
repérer parce que d'ordinaire on les
confond facilement avec d'autres espèces
communes comme bois d'osto qui ont à peu
près les mêmes feuilles et c'est
vraiment les graines et les fleurs qui
nous permettent de la distinguer des
autres dans la végétation quoi l'idée
c'est vraiment de les répertorier pour
que par par la suite s'il y a un
problème sur l'espèce on puisse
récupérer les graines pour mettre en
banque de semence et les replanter
ailleurs
quoi la Vallée Heureuse est une vallée
en cul de sac qui conduit nulle part
excepté à une petite source la source
repiquée perchée dans le
rempart comme souvent la Réunion le
sentier a donc été créé à l'origine pour
accéder à cette source et installer une
canalisation pour conduire l'eau dans
les
bas cette canalisation existe toujours
aujourd'hui deux tuyaux l'un ancien et
l'autre plus récent sont donc visibles
tout au long de la randonnée on peut
voir donc la nouvelle canalisation qui
est en hauteur et celle qui est un peu
plus ancienne qui est à nos pieds là
donc c'est vraiment un élément de repère
qui qui va éviter aux gens de de
s'égarer donc en suivant uniquement la
canalisation à mesure que le sentier
s'enfonce dans la vallée détroués dans
la végétation dégage quelques instants
la vue mais c'est pour mieux replonger
ensuite dans la pénondre du sentier où
la découverte de nombreuses plantes
continue ça c'est une fougère une
fougère qui s'appelle le black nom
tabularé on la trouve essentiellement du
côté du volcan dans le milieu un peu
hcoide et mais ici on la reconnaît pas
forcément parce qu'elle a le stype
vraiment bien bien développé et souvent
recouvert d'e autre mousse encore à
l'époque des premiers botanistes elle
aurait été confondu avec une autre
variété qu'on appelle l'Osmonde c'est
pour cette raisonl que bah on a du côté
du volcan une un endroit qui s'appelle
la plaine des osmondes qui en fait
correspond pas variété mais correspond
plus à cellel le black
t quand la végétation change au profit
des brandes la vue se dégage sur les
reliefs du fond de la vallé
heureuse au-dessus dans le rempart la
source repiqué qu'il vaut mieux éviter
d'aller voir car la fin du senti en
pleine falaise et plus
périlleuseou on peut y préférer la
remontée du bras d'Alx qui offre une
ambiance tout aussi
agréable un choix qui nous permet de
faire aussi une belle découverte
botanique on a la chance de voir de
découvrir une espèce patrimoniale qui
s'appelle parafoasia fontinalis qui est
espèce protégé qui est très rare très
très rare même donc classé vulnérable à
force de faire des recherches de
travailler dessus donc on finit par
avoir l'œil et au final même lorsquon
est en simple randonnée sans être en
prospection on a un petit peu l'œil à
droite à gauche et
effectivement surprise de découvrir ça
mais il faut regarder il faut il faut
s'entraîner à regarder l'objectif c'est
encore de de répertorier de de connaître
les stations qui sont tellement
tellement pauves tellement limite dans
l'île que bah à chaque individu est
important donc celui-là il va aller
encore enrichir la
base
au bout du bras d'Alx la falaise qui
nous fait face matérialise la fin de la
randonnée une option bien sûr à éviter
en cas de forte
pluie
ce que j'aime sur ce sentier c'est
vraiment le côté exubérant le côté
sauvage de la végétation on est ici dans
une au cœur d'une vraie forêt tropicale
humide lorsque le marcheur il vient ici
il faut faut composer avec la végétation
donc il a les branchages dans le visage
on est on est quand même un peu mouillé
donc c'est un sentier qui est au final
assez assez étroit assez confidentiel ce
qui est assez agréable c'est une vallée
qui se finit en C de sac on a
l'impression d'être ici d'être au bout
du monde
et vraiment il y a il y
a il y a vraiment plus des des
sensations ici sensation de de quiétude
voir même quelque chose de de mystique
dans l'air qui qui peut-être à l'origine
du nom de la Vallée Heureuse quoi ce que
j'aime moins sur sur ce randonné on va
dire que ça se passe au niveau de la
première partie sur la route forestière
numéro 37 si on a une voiture basse on
risque de ne pas passer et nous on a eu
la chance de pouvoir passer avec un
véhicule ass haut donc il faudra penser
aussi donc à rajouter des kilomètres en
plus pour pour arriver jusqu'à la vallée
Vallée
heureuse